eight years renee paquette was a
commentator and interviewer for the wwe
she was the first female commentator for
monday night raw and she was never
afraid to mix things up with the boys
i love it renee is now a las vegas
resident she has a new baby on the way
and a new cookbook called messi in the
kitchen that comes out next week
renee welcome to the show before we get
into the cookbook
tell us how is the pregnancy going
you'll be a new mom next month how do
you feel
it's crazy i have four weeks left
the perfect bunch of spots back i
feel great
on my hands now your husband is john
moxley an aew wrestling superstar has he
been hands on did he
put together a nursery for your new baby
a little bit so i'm usually the one
that's pretty hands on
the road that's when i try and tackle
everything i get it all done so i got
the remotes put together
i got the decorations all put together
all of her clothes put away
so we're feeling pretty ready for her
well i love that you guys are las vegas
residents what inspired you to write a
cookbook
i it was just something i wanted to do
it was almost like a bucket list kind of
thing for me you know i was working at
wwe for so long
and it was just this passion project
that i really wanted to do my time on
the road
really made me appreciate my time in my
own house in my own kitchen
and that just made me want to make a
cookbook the recipe
the recipes are very simple that's what
i love about this what are you going to
show us today what do you have for us
okay so we're doing a recipe called eggs
and snow i've already kind of started it
here
um it's super easy all you do is you
separate the egg yolks and the egg
whites
you need about two eggs per slice of
toast
whip up the eggs in a with a hand mixer
a kitchen stand
so you get the nice and fluffy like a
meringue
then you pile them on top of the toast
like
this yes and then you take the back of a
spoon put a little divot in there to put
a little hole
and then with your separated eggs now
i've got them here just pop the egg yolk
back on top there as you see
plop a little cheddar cheese on top
this is so easy to make it is so easy to
make i love this
oh look at we've got a picture of the
final product and that looks delicious
maybe
maybe a night out have a couple drinks
the night before the following morning
that's the perfect breakfast
it is the perfect breakfast if you've
been out on you know having one too many
cocktails it's easy to make
super easy clean up big payoff you can
you can add whatever you wanted to it
too
if you wanted to add some bacon to it
some ham any kind of vegetables
just goes in the oven 375 for about 10
minutes i love it renee thank you so
much again we're so happy you're a las
vegas resident good luck with the with
the baby next month and tell john we
said hi thank you so much
thanks for having me on messy in the
kitchen it comes out may 18th in las
vegas now